Of course, this was a bit of a simple inter quiz here. Yeah, probably that's not a good idea.
Making anybody take this course is a very good idea, but of course, actually you're
the computer scientist so you're supposed to be the one knowing about NP completeness
especially after taken this course.
You'll probably shouldn't say it's impossible.
A better answer would be to say, "It's been proven to be impossible,"
but I think that after this unit, you will agree that the best possible answer is actually to say,
"Well, it's been proven difficult or extremely difficult," but we can actually try
to solve this problem even though it is NP complete and I will show you how to approach that.
The thing is this--there's so many NP complete problems that are practically relevant
that over the past years extremely clever algorithms have been developed for these problems.
They have been developed for vertex cover, for clique, for independent set,
for the shortest tour problem, for SAT, and so on.
Knowing about these problems can really make you standout as a problem solver
because many people, as I said, will give up once they know their problem to be NP complete.
You should respect NP completeness, so maybe not be all smiling when you encounter
NP complete problems, although it's nice to know that they are happy but I don't know.
When they're solving their problem, be respectful but there's no need
to be unhappy or scared of NP completeness.